[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALEXEY KOKIN: Hello, everybody.
It's great to see you here.
My name is Alexi, and I'm
with Google Play Business
Development team.
We work with the top
developers across the globe
to help them grow
on Android platform.
App quality in our Android Deca
System is top priority for us.
If you have been following
our blogs and announcements
in this year, you probably have
noticed two important messages
that we gave--
one in Q1 and second
a few months ago--
that we are going to move away
from just installs and user
ratings in Google Play for
application rankings in Search
and other Google
Play collections.
And we will start focusing
on more complex and focused
metrics, like engagement
or box performance.
Today, we are going to
talk about in detail--
first of all, why it's important
for you to have a quality app.
And we'll talk about what
new tools we have introduced
to help you troubleshoot some
issues in the applications
and also as criteria which
are measured towards your app
quality.
And in the end, we will
discuss how can you
benefit from having
a quality app,
and what can really Google
Play give and reward you
for investing a lot
of time and effort
and building quality
applications.
First of all, let's
start from the basic--
why it's important to have
a quality application.
There are a lot of
components that we
count towards the
quality of applications
inside Google Play.
And we'll talk in more detail
about each and every of some
of those components today.
So when we took a sample
of applications in Play
and measured their
performance, we
have seen that when
the application moves
from average app quality
to good app quality,
they display an
amazing growth in some
of the most important metrics
for the application developers.
For example, they have seen
up to seven times increase
in retention and up to six
times lift in the spending
side of applications.
Those metrics alone can make
or break your application
in your entire
application business.
So this is phenomenal,
and this is
one of the most
crucial things you
can focus on in growing up your
mobile application business.
Our partners, with whom
we work on a daily basis,
they generally confirm our
ideas about applications.
Some examples from them,
for example, [INAUDIBLE]
show significant
growth in user ratings
after performance improvement
of the applications.
They already have a
high rating of 4.1,
and they managed
to grow it to 4.5.
And that's actually
very great results.
Those of you who work on
improving your application
ratings, you definitely
know how difficult
to grow when it's already high.
Another partner, Zalando, they
have focused on reliability,
and performance, and faster
launch, and elimination of bugs
make a lot of impact on their
business critical metrics.
Not only they gain a lot of
traffic from Google Play,
it also provided them
a positive impact
on the monitoring metric, on the
LTV lifetime [INAUDIBLE] users.
It's clear for us that users
love great applications.
They tend to use them more.
And therefore, they tend to
use and poor them more goods
through such applications.
And finally, the app quality
is the most important factor
for your application
rating in Google Play.
Every Uber driver knows
that only one-star rating
hurts you more than a
five-star rating helps.
And with the
statistics like that,
50% of negative
reviews, as I mentioned,
stability and box, and
60% of positive reviews
mention stuff like speed
design and performance.
You know what to focus
on to get higher ratings
and get a good quality app.
Android Vitals is our
newest step in attempt
to help you build better
applications, which
we announced this May on
Google IU in San Francisco.
This is an initiative by
Google to improve the stability
in performance of the
entire Android device
on entire Android Deca Systems.
And you, as
application developers,
are the important
part of this effort.
We are starting by focusing
on the three main performance
areas for the requitals.
Those are stability, and
battery, and renderings.
By collecting a lot of
data from Android devices
all over the world,
we analyze and flag
bad behaviors inside
the applications
to give you a little
bit more insight
how your app different
from other apps on Play,
and what areas you should focus
on to improve your application
quality.
Our partners, again,
support us in this activity.
And if you're speaking about
actual game or application
stability and performance
on device here,
even the biggest
players on the market
can benefit on doing some actual
good work toward increasing
these numbers.
For example, Kabam reports
massive growth on retention
after improving the
application performance.
And everybody in this
audience should definitely
know how important
this retention
metric is for your application's
successful monetization.
So our three main
areas-- our first
are is stability, where
we focus on crushes
and ANRs, Application
Not Responding--
when the application is
frozen for five seconds or so.
Our second major
focus point is battery
because the main concern here
is not to overly, excessively
use battery of your device.
And the third focus
area is rendering
because where you can really
enjoy your device when
everything is rendered
fast and smooth, at 60
frames per seconds.
And a lot of
things, if you're UI
is slow one and
unresponsive, it definitely
removes some pleasure from using
the device for the application.
So to track all of
those three major areas,
we've added new sections in Play
Console called Android Vitals.
And so if there is
one thing you will
do after this presentation
is just you go and log
in into your developer
console, and check this section
for some new insights.
I will consider my
mission a success.
And if you will analyze some
of the data in this area
and plan some
performance improvements
based on the
statistic available,
then, well, you are the best.
And the best thing about Vitals
is that they already work.
So you don't have to
implement new SDK.
You don't have to
increase your APK size.
You don't have to do anything
because those statistics are
available to you right
now for each and every
of your applications.
We gather them from
Android platform
and from those users
who have opted in
in sharing the diagnostic
information with us.
So if you want to
help, you should also
opt in into this option
on your device too.
It will help us,
and we will help you
with those data and statistics.
So let's go to the
stability areas.
And I probably will not be
focusing a lot on crashes
because each and every one of
you know how to handle crushes.
You definitely catch them.
You analyze them.
You're trying to fix them.
But ANRs, which we call the
application not responding,
they happen when the
application freezes and stops
responding for input
because of deadlocks
or long operations
inside the applications.
Those ANRs are definitely
disruptive for user experience.
And they negatively
impact user behaviors.
And other issue with ANRs is
that you typically cannot use
a crash report as the
key to catch them.
But we can because the
platform reports ANRs to us,
and we share this information
with you in Android Vitals.
You can head over to the
ANR section of your console,
and you will see a lot of
information of the performance
and number of ANRs in different
job applications builts,
on different devices
and application,
and operation system versions.
If there are a lot of ANRs
in one particular built,
we will definitely flag it
as with exclamation point.
And we generally consider
that a lot means more than 5%.
So if something
is above 5%, it's
definitely something to focus
on and to analyze about.
There are a lot of additional
statistics in this particular--
here, you can see, for example,
your crash-free and ANR-free
rate.
And you can drill down to
see some additional stats
about how many
users were impacted,
and what devices and Android
versions were affected.
That's all about ANRs, but there
is one fundamental question.
How much do they matter?
And we have found out that
they matter actually a lot.
And we have analyzed some of
the applications on Google Play.
And we saw that applications
with high ANR rates--
again, about 5--
they are around 30%
more one-day uninstallations
than more stable apps.
So if you want to avoid having
a lot of uninstallations,
focus on those and
eliminate crashes and INRs.
Even big developers,
for example,
like Twitter here is a
benefit from this information
and then benefit from
these statistics.
And Android Vitals
and ANR help them
improve experience for actually
hundreds of millions of users
all over the globe.
Next, to the battery--
it's a top concern
for us at Google,
and our Android team
is working constantly
on making some good improvements
to increase the battery
life of each and every device.
And the best way to
keep the battery alive
is to shut down most of the
features, most of the hardware,
which is not used right now.
But you, as an
application developer,
when you need some
additional processing
power for your
applications, you definitely
can keep the device alive.
And in case of
some trouble, there
are two bad behaviors which can
cost significant battery life--
stuck wake locks and
excessive wakeups.
Wake locks-- you
definitely know that you
can keep the device awake
when you need some processing
power to do something
within your applications.
There is a full wake lock,
which is not that bad.
When the full wake lock
is performed on device,
the screen is on, and the
user is usually actively using
the device-- like
playing a game,
or driving a car with the screen
on, or watching some videos.
And the user knows that,
well, he's doing something
with the device.
And probably, he wasted
all of the battery.
So it's not a high
priority concern.
The high priority concern
is partial wake lock,
when the screen is off,
but the application
is still doing something
in the background.
And sometimes, this
activity can stuck,
and this wake lock can work
for really a long time--
for example, more than an hour.
And when the wake lock is
stuck for more than an hour,
we definitely flag
it as a bad behavior
inside the applications and show
it to you in Android Vitals.
Again, if you head to
the specific section
of the development
console, you can
see a lot of statistics,
where we show you
how many stuck wake locks
you've had in your applications,
the particular build and the
particular Android version.
The good behavior
is to have a wake
lock for less than one minute.
It's optimal for
battery-saving perspective.
And if there is a wake
lock for more than an hour,
it's something
definitely going wrong.
Why is it important?
We had our own internal study
for all devices inside Google.
And we have found out that in
30% of cases, when the user had
issues with the
battery discharge
and with a low lifetime value,
low lifetime of the device,
it was caused by those
stuck wake locks.
So keep an eye on them,
and try to our solve
this in order not to create
a bad experience for users.
Other things are wakeups,
when you can wake up
the device in a
specific period of time
to perform some
kind of operations.
Again, if you do
this more often,
it will drain
battery more rapidly.
And we look at that as bad
behavior for 10 or more wakeups
per hour.
So if you do it
10 times or more,
it's something
you can definitely
look after and probably try to
decrease the amount of wakeups
in this case.
Again, there are
statistics which show you
which specific API
causes the wakeup
and how many times per hour.
And the worst case
scenario is, of course,
if you have a wakeup,
which then becomes stuck.
Then, it really means
that the battery will be
drained in a really fast way.
So this is the main point to
avoid in terms of battery life.
And the last thing, but probably
not the least, is rendering.
And as I said
before, it generally
creates a very pleasant
feeling when the app
is running fast and smooth.
We are tracking two
major points here--
the slow rendering
and frozen frames.
And the slow rendering is
when 50% of frames, they
render with the time greater
than 16 milliseconds--
and a frozen frame, when
some specific frame is stuck
for 700 milliseconds or more.
And if you have a lot
of those, again, we
will flag it in the console.
And you'll be able to see
how fast your UI is rendered,
and what is going on
with those frozen frames.
In addition to
the frozen frames,
we will also note
the slow UI when
there is a UI thread which
has a lot of processing
activity going within
it, which decreases
the speed of rendering
of the entire interface.
Again, this is
something to look for it
and probably move this
activity to the ground thread.
So using Vitals to
identify and troubleshoot
app technical issues and
make the app more stable
is one thing which is
critically important now
when we're using it
actively to measure the app
success on Google Play Store.
But there are other components
of application quality
which are equally important.
And I'm going to talk about
them in the next session.
So what's a quality app?
First things first--
reliability and performance,
we already more
or less discussed
this using the Android
Vitals discussion.
Then, there should be
some actual features
which users love.
There should be some
beautiful design, which
follows our platform
guidelines, and as applications
should really focus on
supporting all the latest
features and technologies
platform has.
This will create a wonderful
experience for the users,
and this will make the users
love your applications more.
First things first,
the material design--
we have been speaking about
material design for two
or three years already.
And in general, material design
got a lot of positive feedback
not only from Google itself,
but from independent designers
and developers all
over the world.
There a lot of materials on how
to implement material design
and how to build
your applications in
according with our guidelines.
And you can easily
find them online.
Remember that just using some of
the pre-built components, which
are all provided to you
by material design team,
is not enough to
be fully compliant
with the requirements.
In order to be really
design-focused,
you should design
your application
from the ground up keeping the
main concept of material design
in mind.
And having some
universal patterns
within the applications
on Android platform,
having familiar patterns and
elements within the application
design really helps our
users to be more engaged
with applications on Android.
And it really helps them to
start using your applications
faster--
result, big learning curve.
Next thing, next big
thing is platform support.
First of all, a quality
app is an up-to-date app.
So you should always check
your application stability
and performance against the
latest version of the operation
system.
And you should definitely
use the latest SDK
that is available to build
and compile the applications.
In addition to that, there is a
lot of other Android platforms
out there.
And the more of
them you support,
the better it is for
your application quality.
Remember that there are plenty
of devices running on Android
out there-- wearables,
tablets, smart TVs, VR
devices, connected cars.
Not every platform is of course
relevant for your application
use case.
But when it is, consider
supporting the most relevant
platform because it will be
definitely a positive thing
for your application.
For example, smart TVs, when the
user is using your application
not on a mobile device
but on smart TV,
the user tends to spend a lot
of time before a big screen.
And it means a better engagement
for your entire application.
Wearables-- wearables
are mostly--
I think in 75% of the
cases-- used for fitness.
And if the user is buying
and using wearables,
he is definitely the most
engaged and most focused
users you can have
because he already
had several devices
which he uses frequently.
Getting on the wearable
means your application
will stay not only on the wear
device, but on the smartphone
too.
And the users will return
to your applications
each time they go
for the workout.
VR, there are a lot of
buzz words against VR,
and there are definitely
a lot of new use cases
which are emerging right now.
VR has its own, very
specific usage pattern.
So for example, users
will most definitely
have longer but less
frequent sessions
with your VR application.
And there are a lot of new
ways to interact and display
your content to the users
within the virtual reality
environment.
Next thing is monetization.
And we definitely believe
that if a user loves
your application so
much, so he's actually
ready to pay for your
content or your services,
it's a great indication of
your application quality.
So when you pass a
certain threshold
in selling your premium app,
or through in-app purchases,
or through
subscriptions, we will
start counting it towards
your app quality rating
and supporting of Android
Pay for relevant scenarios
in the countries where
Android Pay is available.
And I want to remind
you that Poland
is one of the first
countries in Europe
which actually launched
and supported Android Pay.
It's all so great,
and you should
focus on experimenting with this
new and interesting technology.
Next thing is to think
about the easiness of usage
for your application
for your users.
Use technologies like Smart
Lock and signing in with Google
to enable the users
to create accounts
or sign in into your
profile faster and easier.
And focus on communicating with
the users who are leaving you
feedback and maybe raise
some issues in their reviews
to keep your rating above four.
So when your application
rating is four or more,
it basically opens you
each and every door
for all featuring activities
for collection inclusions
and stuff like that.
So this is important.
And talking with users in their
own language in the reviews
sections will help you
provide great feedback
and communicate with them.
Moving from the application
itself to some tools
you have in your Google
Play listings and metadata.
First of all, there are a lot of
things, videos, graphics, texts
you can add to your
Google Play listing
to make it engaging
and interesting.
Then you can use A/B
testing to see what works
and what doesn't on
this specific listing.
And you can beta test your apps
for alpha and beta channel.
The Play listing has a
lot of things to work on.
And when you're starting to
think about your App Store
optimization, this is your
number one destination.
Title, I can feature graphic
videos and stuff like that.
They all can be
localized and present it
to each user in each particular
country in their own language.
This, of course,
does wonders in terms
of organic store conversion.
And to see what works
and what doesn't, you
can use A/B testing to run
some experiments as globally
or in a specific
language and understand
what specific graphic
screenshot, or text, or title
works better for a specific
region and specific users.
Why it's important?
Because it's one
of the best things
to improve your organic
conversion rate.
17% for Wallapop here is not
the top number you can get.
There are some developers who
get up to 30% more conversions
after fully optimizing
their Google Play listings.
And remember, for
successful experiment,
you should have a
clear hypothesis
which you are testing.
And you should have some
really different variations
of a design you are testing.
They shouldn't be very
similar, or results
won't be very conclusive.
And the last session
of our presentation
is to talk about what you can
get from creating the best
quality app.
There are main things
and main benefit
of having a healthy app.
It's through getting
more visibility in search
and automatic discourage tools.
You can get featured by
our Google Play team,
and you can get recognized
and receive certain award
from our colleagues.
So first thing first, is the
visibility, promotability,
and discoverability.
The better your app
quality rating is,
and the better your Android
Vitals, and the better iUsers
review, the more
traffic you will
start getting from Google
Play Store organically.
As I told in the beginning of
our presentation, engagement,
app quality, Android
Vitals crashes,
all things like that,
they impact the ratings
in, first of all, in the search.
So when the user searches
for applications,
we use a lot of criteria
to rank applications.
And having everything great
in terms of applications
will help you boost your
application to the top,
and get more traffic,
and get more visible.
In addition to this, there are
a lot of different collections
inside Google Play Store.
For example, an app like
Travelers, app for work,
app for leisure,
and stuff like that.
And around 90% of
those collections,
they are now automated.
So they are created through a
machine-running algorithm which
pick up applications and
group them for a similar theme
or similar functionality.
And in order to get in
those collections more,
you should have a
better app quality
because those algorithms they
prioritize high-quality apps
before average quality
apps for inclusions
in those collections.
And again, each and
every Google Play user,
they see a different Google
Play Homepage each time they
open the Google Play Store.
And we try to shows
them the content
they might be more
interested in.
So having quality apps
means you will be included
in more automated collections.
And those collections
will be shown
to the users who are the most
relevant for your application
use case.
And this will get you not just
regular installation, not just
regular organic traffic, but
focused and relevant traffic
with users who are more
likely to stay and use
your applications.
Next thing is you can get
featured and be included
in those collections, which
are currently not automated,
and which are curated
and handpicked
by our merchandising team and
my colleagues within Google Play
Business Development
and Merchandising.
Each and every app which
is nominated for featuring
goes through an extensive
review from our tech ops team.
And tech ops team
analyzes its app quality,
analyzes its design
and its features,
and provides some
of the feedback,
and provides some of the
requirements for improvement--
which doesn't deliver to the
developers before the app gets
featured.
If those requirements
are met, the application
is included in some of
our future collections--
for example, like new
and updated collections--
and get a lot of traffic
during the featuring period.
Again, app quality
was always a factor
for our featuring requirements.
And now, we have a lot of,
well, formal requirements.
For example, your rating
should be more than four.
You should have a good rating
in terms of Android Vitals.
So getting your apps up-to-date
in terms of app quality
is the number one
priority and number
one required prerequisite
before getting featured.
Again, featuring is usually
very important for developers
in terms of marketing
and optics perspective.
So if you get featured,
it's a great story
for a Facebook post.
And you can definitely
feel appreciated.
But the traffic you can get
from, well, a week of featuring
is usually--
well, it's quite big of course.
But the traffic
you get organically
from improving your
applications over the course
of several months,
of several years
of being prioritized in
searches, also included
in the automated collections,
is generally better, bigger,
and more valuable than this
one-time featuring boost.
So working on app
quality for featuring
is great because it
gets you visibility.
But long-term benefits
of having quality apps,
they deliver better
results over time.
And the last thing
currently is you
can get recognized and get
specific award in the Google
Play.
Currently, we have two types
of awards and recognitions.
First of all, it's
Editor's Choice,
which is done by our colleagues
in Google Play Merchandising.
And we usually give
the Editor's Choice
to the most trending
application.
So if there is one app or
game which gets a lot of buzz
on social media,
which is new and hot,
it can get into
Editor's Choice and be
featured as an Editor Choice
application for the week.
And there is
another award, which
is called Android
Excellence, which
we have launched just
a few months ago in May
of this year--
which showcases
best Android apps
on the platform, which
are the best in terms
of application quality,
design feature, reliability,
and user feedback.
So getting the Android
Excellence Award
is quite hard in terms of,
well, effort and activities
you have to do in order
to get this recognition.
But those awarded applications
are really the best Android
apps there are.
And if you are looking
somewhere for inspiration,
or if you're looking
for best practices,
just head out to the
Android Excellence
portion of the
Google Play Store,
and check it out because there
are definitely applications you
can check, you can download.
And you can probably reuse
some of their know-how
in your own applications.
That's about all.
We will have some office
hours later this day.
And if you have some additional
questions about how featuring,
how Google Play works,
how to get featured,
and how to improve your
applications quality, please
come in.
And we can discuss
it one-on-one.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]